ordering us intelligence to redouble
their efforts to find out exactly where
the coronavirus came from
that is after his administration shut
down an investigation led by former
secretary of state mike pompeo to do
the same thing biden putting out a
statement today that says the intel
community is split between two likely
scenarios oncova's origin
a wuhan lab leak or animal to human
contact
they now have 90 days to report back to
the president republican senators argue
biden didn't really have a choice
joe biden and the democrats need to stop
their cover-up
that is benefiting the chinese
communists at the expense of the
american people
the only reason that biden's doing this
is becoming untenable not to look into
whether or not
the virus originated in the chinese lab
we need to find out what happened so it
never happens again
if the source of covert 19 that turned
the world upside down
is from a lab in china we need to hold
china but accountable
all right jesse so here we are i have a
little list um i thought you would like
it but i'll do it quickly
um when pompeo cotton others remember
they they say that could have come from
a lab they're ridiculed we'll talk about
that in a moment as well
um then pompeo and us intelligence
starts this investigation biden gets
elected
shuts it down now says that national
security council will do it but when all
of that
is happening the wall street journal has
a story that says
actually three people in china went to
the hospital actually that looks like it
could be
coming from a lab and now all of a
sudden there's a new investigation and
redoubling of efforts
how does this sit with you so you get
joe's schedule every day
usually maybe one kind of half event
comes out
today the schedule comes out he has
nothing nothing
he has no events very light day i don't
know what he does
so on a day that he has nothing to do
and the report comes out that says he
just killed the investigation into the
lab
he comes out and releases this big
statement and says oh we are going to
investigate
this lab theory and it was a day after
the white house press secretary
said we didn't need to actually do this
investigation
come on and now the spin comes out that
oh yeah the people that were doing the
investigation for trump
yeah it was kind of sloppy right the guy
doing it was a
bloodhound dana he investigated al qaeda
finances
he worked for both parties he's a legit
resume
so i don't trust whatever the
intelligence team's going to put out for
joe biden
no credibility to me they could have
some good people in there some patriots
but he hired a bunch of russia hoaxers
trump haters
corporate lobbyists in there they're not
going to get to the bottom of it
and he's right the cover-up continues
the question is who are they coming up
for
coming up for fouchy are they covering
up for china and corporate america are
they covering up for hunter
has hunter even divested from that
investment fund i don't think he has
so what's going on here um let me just
play
like some logic here dana if it didn't
come
from a wet market okay if if it came
say it came from a wet market then why
two weeks after the pandemic was
unleashed did the wet markets go back
up and running why do they still have
wet markets all over china
i mean if it came from a wet market
wouldn't the chinese say yeah this is
where it came from
we're going to ban this and point to the
species that it came from
no instead what they did was they
silenced and disappeared the scientist
erased all the files at the lab and now
the state media and china blame the u.s
military for unleashing it does that
sound like someone has everything under
control
it does not and then there's a media
angle greg i love this paragraph from
jim garrity of national reviews he was
writing about the lab leak possibility
and he got
absolutely ridiculed so today he writes
this you morons idiot schmucks you all
sat there so smug and confident that you
were the smart ones and
knuckle-dragging little me with my
youtube video from an expat
google translate versions of chinese
state health agency websites
and old medical research papers had to
be chasing bigfoot and elvis and ufos
set up the buffet table of crow because
i want to watch all of you eat a lot of
it
will they do that no they won't in fact
they're they're not trying to cover up
anything they're just trying to cover
their butts
by the way uh i have to you know we have
to
express some sympathy for the wet market
industry
uh i've been on the line with the
national wet market association trade
association
and they've been hit pretty hard by this
and it's going to take a while for the
wet market industry
to bounce back from this unfair smear
uh the pangolins the bats
you know delicious delicious but no
one's eating them dana but i think you
know what happens this is just another
example of
uh whatever trump does no matter if it's
right we can't do it if he
found the solution to aging cnn
would come out in favor of euthanasia so
they cannot they cannot be on the same
side as him even though
it turns out that he's been he's got a
pretty good batting average if you look
at
you know one probably the first per
first real you know uh
loudest voice on china right even before
the pandemic
the travel ban remember when he when he
pushed operation warp speed
and we can't trust the vax said the
media
said biden said we can't trust that
because
trump what does that sound like just
sounds like it sounds like this
we can't trust what's the what the truth
is because it's trump
even though it's the truth and this is
where the big problem lies
even if trump was wrong about something
you should still do the news you
idiot i'm starting starting to sound
like garrity these are two separate
issues
they're two separate issues like you
could say i don't like trump
therefore i don't trust him on this
issue but i should really
explore the lab leak since it seems to
be
the simplest explanation you should be
able to do both of them
that's not on trump that's on the news
one why do you think the administration
all of a sudden announced today a
redoubling of efforts in 90 days to
report back
well i think you said it dana we now
have from intelligence sources reports
about these
two or three people apparently people
who were at the lab who got sick and
this would be going back into
much earlier than we knew uh and got
sick with symptoms we're not sure but
could be
that they got sick with symptoms of
covis so we have more
information from public sources that
would justify that kind of investigation
i mean right now there should be there's
no question it needs to be an
investigation
there are more conspiracy theories and
origin theories about this than the
kennedy assassination so
we need to get to the bottom of it you
can't trust china in my opinion because
it's a repressive authoritarian regime
where the truth can get you killed um so
i think that we've got to somehow find a
way to get this done now
you know you guys are talking about what
pompeo did i'm not sure pompeo was the
right guy to do this because
remember the trump administration
handled colvin so badly
that i think lots of people like pompeo
would are
glad to somehow look at origins to just
try to distract and change the subject
and get away from their own
responsibilities so i think you know
even here in this country give you an
idea of political pressures and
investigations
we can't get together and say let's have
an investigation of january 6 an attack
on our own capital
imagine what's going on in china can i
just say something to correct something
juan said the
state department under trump in january
put out a fact sheet that said these
guys got sick in 2019
that was out three months ago that's not
new juan right right
taken last three months in other words
not when pompeo started yeah but today
he all announces this okay all right
dagon last word to you
trump handled the coronavirus epidemic
badly one word on that
vaccine um you know what this is one of
the
biggest stories certainly in my lifetime
and to quote greg gutfeld common sense
is the enemy of ideologues especially
stupid lazy ideologues
and i mean the media so from day one
people on fox and fox business were
talking about
the wuhan virology lab which we knew
was performing gain of function research
on coronaviruses which means to make
them
more deadly to ramp up their spread
we knew that but what was the media
doing siding
with the communist party of china
instead of a
sitting u.s senator tom cotton who was
talking about this virology lab more
than a year ago
so that's where the media is and they're
still doing it
peter ducey asked jin saki about this
very
issue two days ago and yesterday and
that
idiot site what is it meteoritis
was writing mocking stories about peter
ducey and then today the whole white
house press corps is like
trying to ask jennasaki about it it's
one of the biggest stories of our
lifetime
but oh trump that bad dictator in charge
meantime three and a half million people
are dead because of communist china and
a virus that
likely came from that lab there's a
little bit of that temper she told us
about in the a black hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else